[موسيقى]
ويا هلا ويا مرحبا حياكم الله معانا فل
عاصمه مسقط مقر الحكم والاداره والشورى
تفاصيل كثيره راح تعرفونا معنا على فين
وكيف تقضون الوقت اذا كنت راح تزورونها
سواء كان مرور او اكثر من 24 ساعه لكن لا
اقدر اقول لكم اياه مسجد قابوس الاوبرا
السلطانيه من اهم المعالم هنا
[موسيقى]
هالو هالو من كورنيش مطرح بعيد عن العاصمه
مسقط حول نصف ساعه بس هذا الشاطئ يعد من
اجمل شواطئ العالم العربي له مزايا كثيره
اللون الموج النظافه والموقع من اليسار
راح تحصلون كل الاسواق الشعبيه والمشربيات
وتقدرون تمشون على رجولكم تقطعون الشارع
على الجهه اليمين راح تلاقون الشط والساحل
فيه خوت للايجار في مطاعم فيما ماشي خاصه
للي حبني يمارسون الرياضه في مجال خاصه
للعوائل اللي حابين يفطرون يتغدون يتعشون
ولا اروع ولا اجمل على طاري النظافه انا
استغربت اصلا النظافه
سيجاره او رميت علبه مويه من السياره ممكن
تتخانق ثلاث الاف ريال سعودي واذا رميتها
متعمد بحر او في مكان عام مثلا في الحدائق
ممكن يوصل موضوع الى سجن عشر ايام مصادره
السياره والمخالفه الماديه تتضاعف
[موسيقى]
وينك
كذا بريك سريع ولطيف انا انصحكم انكم
تيجوا المطعم كلاود الي داخل المجمع الكهف
للمطاعم هذه المجمع وهذا المجمع متصمم كده
على ستايل الكهف لانه جزء وتركيبه من جمال
المنطقه
المشهورها وبيجيبها لها حلات هذا المكان
انه صاير فوق جبال عندكم اطلاله مميزه في
الليل وقت المغرب لسه اجمله عندكم البلده
الحديثه والبلده القديمه
مسقط مسقط من الدول الوحيده او شبه
الوحيده اللي يعني كل بيوتها لون واحد انا
حاستمتع باجواء راح اخذ بريك جدا سريع
عشان نكمل معكم المشوار على فين بعد شويه
حخبركم بعد ما اشرب عصير شكرا لك عزيزي
يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]
الله
صارت جاهزه خبزتين يعطيكم العافيه
في خبز في الدنيا الريح لحالها رائعه طبعا
انا سويت اختراع اليوم حطيت جبن وحطيت
زعتر
الجديده كثيره طبعا الخبز العماني بيعتمد
على ثلاث مكونات فقط دقيق البر القمح
الكامل والمي والملح
وانواعه تعتمد على سماكته
سماكه الخبزه وايضا كميه الميه اللي
موجوده في في العجينه
بتخليها سمكها ايضا فاذا كانت همم خفيفه
جدا مثل المي يسموه خبز مرشش
الست بتعمل بس كده مثل الشبك ويصير يسموه
خبز المشرق
بهذه العجينه بهذا السم يسووا ثلاثه انواع
خبز رقاق او الخبز اليابس يسموه خبز
الرخال وخبز الجوله
ايضا يصنع منها حلويات كثيره
هالو هالو اعجوبه جديده من عجايب الطبيعه
في السلطنه قالوا ان في نيزك ضرب الارض
بقوه جدا كبيره قبل مئات السنين وين نزل
نزل في الحفره اللي ورانا مع مرور السنين
والمويه اللي تيجي من الامطار ومن
الينابيع والعيون تجمعت قدامنا هذه
البحيره من الماء هل هذا الشيء صحيح هل هي
خرافه هل هو منطق المهم انه احنا جينا
هالمكان الحلو ونازلين نستكشفها
الناس تدفع الاف مؤلفه عشان تحصل مثل
هالعنايه وسباق خاص هنا في سمك جدا صغير
ياكل الجلد الميت هنا الدخول مجاني
هالمنتزه فاحنا ماخذين هذه الخدمه مجانيه
اما بالنسبه للشعور في شويه دغدغه ولسعه
السمكه اول شيء
تخرعون في الامان
[موسيقى]
هالو هالو مكمله معاكم بريحه البخور اللي
يشكل قلب شك جابني من اخر الشارع نتكلم عن
شارع المشاكيك المشاكيك العمانيه حكلمكم
عنها اكثر واكثر كانت تجربتي عند عصوم ولا
اروع قالوا لي تحدي هلال راح يفوز على
عصوم انت وش قولك
اكيد الصوت
[موسيقى]
يا سلام يا سلام على الريحه اه
طبعا يحطوا له صوص الصبار اللي هو عباره
عن التمر الهندي مع شويه تلومي هنا
العمانيين يحبون الطعم الحامض يحبون
الحموضه على اساس انها فاتح للشهيه وتعطي
نكهه جدا مميزه مو مستحيل تحصونا في اي
دوله في العالم الا في عمان وشارع مسقط
هذا اللي نتكلم عنه مشهور بالمشاكيل
[موسيقى]
هلا هلا هلا
بالحامل والمحمول يا اخي جوعتني
جوسي خفيفه جدا لان الخبز جدا خفيف الصوت
جدا خفيف
نكهه بخيره اللحم
مش طبيعيه
والله العظيم لذيذ والله روعه
[موسيقى]
شبعانين جوعانين مو مهم لان ريحه المشاكل
العمانيه راح تجيبكم عبر اميال موقعهم
قريب من المطار يفتحوا من الساعه 6:00
والى ما بعد الساعه 12:00 الساعه 1:00 بعد
نص الليل عندهم دجاج لحم بالصلصات الخاصه
عندهم برجر عندهم ريش وعندهم حبار مو مهم
ايش تشتهي المهم هذه اللعبه
بكره الصلاه
[موسيقى]